[Musique]
la kfw 19 suscite peut-être de la peur
en vous et c'est normal le danger c'est
de croire n'importe quoi
vous avez sûrement vu passer une
kyrielle d'avertissement tous genres sur
les réseaux sociaux
parlons de cette publication virale que
plusieurs d'entre vous nous avez envoyé
on ignore qui en est l'auteur puisqu'on
y affirme c'est que du 23 mars au 3
avril le nombre de cas positifs va
augmenter de façon très importante
d'autres versions de cette même
publication affirme que la période visée
est plutôt du 27 mars au 9 avril
cette prédiction est elle vraie et elle
valide
en fait elle n'est pas totalement fausse
selon l'épidémiologiste nimâ machouf que
ma collègue des décrypteurs bouchra
wathiq interrogées selon docteur machouf
on se trouve exactement au coeur de la
période de l'épidémie où le nombre de
cas va être plus significatif cette
semaine sera donc très difficile sur le
moral d'un peu tout le monde selon elle
cela dit d'autres affirmations contenues
dans cette publication sont fausses
il est faux de croire que jusqu'au 3
avril il ne faut pas sortir de la maison
et je cite même pour aller chercher du
pain car le pire commence fin de
citation cette mise en garde est non
fondée selon docteur machouf qui vous
recommande de faire exactement ce que la
santé publique nous dit frère depuis
deux semaines c'est à dire sortir
uniquement pour des besoins essentiels
et se laver les mains
dès qu'on rentre à la maison les seules
exceptions ceux qui ont des symptômes de
lakovic 19 ou ceux qui sont revenus de
voyage depuis moins de 14 jours autre
élément qui doit vous faire douter de
l'importance de ce genre de publication
on y affirme que le personnel qui
travaille à l'hôpital souhaite que ce
message soit diffusé à tous sans jamais
préciser de quel hôpital il s'agit
certains des internautes qui ont envoyé
cette publication décrypteurs avait
entendu dire que ça émanait d'hôpitaux
ou de médecins québécois
cette rumeur est tout simplement sans
fondement c'est important de noter que
des messages presque identique circule
aussi à l'étranger où ils ont été
attribués à plusieurs hôpitaux en france
et au royaume uni
donc
les cas les autorités concernées ont
démenti être les auteurs de ce message
pour plus de détails sur cette
publication n'hésitez pas à lire
l'article de bouchra wathiq sur notre
page web et continuer à nous signaler
des publications qui vous paraissent
trompeuses ou sur lesquels vous avez des
doutes leurs courriels et notre groupe
facebook sont là pour ça